une scène tournée par un vidéaste
amateur au coeur de port-au-prince
des policiers tentent de déjouer des
membres de gagne d'autres quartiers sont
simplement abandonnés par les forces de
l'ordre
jeunes hommes lourdement armés qui
opèrent en toute impunité
et les dernières victimes sont des
enfants de la commune de cité soleil à
port au prince qui ont fui les
affrontements
quelques 300 d'entre eux ont trouvé
refuge dans une école marie love a vu
une élève perdre la vie dans un échange
de coups de feu oui lave les mains
la situation est complexe
essentiellement deux bandes s'affrontent
léger peuple et le g9 menée par l'anssi
policy tristement célèbre sur les
réseaux sociaux zargis michaud rien aux
attaques certaines zones qu'ils
aimeraient contrôler et le groupe à 30
sont en gros qui n'est pas
nécessairement uniforme messager peup
journaux n'est en tout cas comme ça et
ils se défendent leur quartier en disant
non nous on veut la sécurité dans le
quartier on veut retrouver la casse et
les flambées de violence ne sont pas
nouvelles à port au prince mais la
montée rapide de ses gagne préoccupe les
nations unies en seulement six mois le
nu recense 934 meurtre
684 blessés et 680 enlèvement
montréal le sujet fait partie des
conversations des membres de la diaspora
comme touche du jour en jour n'ont que
j'entends qu'est ce qui se passe en
haïti et nous sommes facilement tomber
sur ceux qui ont été pris pour cible
comme cette mère pendant que je sautais
à l'école avec mon fils là on a et on a
essayé de nous quitte nappe est là et
c'est là j'ai dit j'ai parlé avec mon
mari je lui dis que non je ne peux pas
rester là-bas je ne sais pas ce qui va
se passer après cet analyste de la
question ici nc sur les réseaux sociaux
des émissions dédiées à l'histoire
d'haïti et sa politique il soulève une
série de questions d'où viennent ces
armes-là par où elle transite qui a
l'argent pour les acheter qui
al'autorité
pour les faits rentrée et la cinquième
question je ne sait plus à quelle
question je suis maintenant c'est à
quelle finalité je crois que c'est la
question la plus importante
il fait partie de ceux qui prônent une
solution interne à la crise la soi
disant communauté internationale doit
laisser aux haïtiens le temps de trouver
une solution
un trahissent les pays amis comme le
canada et les états unis prônent une
solution haïtienne qui passeraient entre
autres par la tenue d'élections
organisées par le gouvernement en place
un gouvernement qui a montré peu de
résultats jusqu'à présent dans sa lutte
contre la violence il ses ministres
françois radio canada montréal